dude this is wild you're in a superhero
film what was your favorite detail that
you had to throw into your character to
really satisfy the fans it could be from
the comic book it could be from Beyond
there's so much to it I think wanting to
honor his past and his family but not
shove that into people's faces but
really just kind of have the Nuance of
it in there that was important to me
yeah
his uncle's a superhero and he comes
from like he comes from a pretty
precarious past as well with superheroes
and villainy and whatnot so interesting
now I heard
oh oh no I heard that you had to have
your suit ripped off of you because you
dislocated your arm not once but twice
yeah that's the story behind that oh my
God watch Jimmy Fallon I tell it shake
it take us back what was that so it was
a great day so I was doing sprints I was
sprinting a lot I was coming off a
sidewalk and there were parked cars and
I thought on the last deck I thought let
me try to make you thought you were a
superhero I was like well I just wanted
to make it funny you know we've done it
serious so many times let's see if we
can add humor to it and it was funny
because I I pretended to hit my knee I
spun around threw my arm in the air and
it just dislocated completely so uh I
tried to get it back and didn't want to
go back in so they cut it open and on
the 13th try to got it back in but I was
so excited that it went back in and I
was like yeah and it went right out
again
superhero you're going to be a spy in
the recruit what do you want to take on
next oh man I guess we'll just have to
find out
[Music]